all right madison well many of us going
to bed last night just trying to contain
the rain it even happened to us right
here in our channel 8 studios in fact i
shared some of that on social media last
night we were ducking some of the
raindrops literally inside our studio so
we asked our david charns about what you
can do if maybe you've got a leaky roof
today david what'd you find out
well denise we are live here on the 8
news now roof and like many of you at
home we have a flat roof and that can
cause problems here and more problems
when you get debris like this stuck in
your storm drain and like we saw here
last night leads to some issues
it's not the sound anyone wants to hear
from the inside rain coming into a home
or building in this case thursday night
it was one of our own studios what
happens when that water gets in to their
house as a contract alex harritunian's
reaction says it all
water may be the source of life but it's
not a good thing when it looks like this
i'm looking where the water went to you
see a water here but that water is able
to travel all the way to the
other room or the bathrooms
his company all-state service group is
on the front lines of the cleanup
that's because rain coming through your
roof will find any means necessary to
cause damage whether it's getting
everything wet or sticking around in the
walls is that type of insurance
something that people here in southern
nevada generally have it really depends
on their policy so typically you're
going to have some coverage but it just
depends on the cause of the flood susan
bauman is the executive director of
nevada independent insurance agents even
though you think your insurance covers
everything she says if it could have
been prevented your policy may not cover
it like having a very old roof or not
clearing out the drains you're
responsible for if it's due to
the management of maintaining your home
or your business then there might be
some liability that falls on you the
best thing our contractor and our
insurance agents say prepare for the
next storm it's going to damage the
house
so you can check your policy of course
with your insurance agent and also if
you plan on hiring a contractor you can
always search their license with the
state contractor's board live on the
roof tonight i'm david charns live local
now